salut dépêchez-vous françois et casimir
sont en train de jouer au jeu des
contraires
ça fait rien s'est bien gardée bien
saisi mur oui oui c'est ça et puis ça on
dit rien quand on fait un bond s'est
terminée qu'on rs3 presse alors les
chiens gentils méchants et les gentils
c'est ça c'est ça mais je suis gentil
expliqué type explique un petit peu la
pression mais on peut expliquer un petit
peu oui non mais les gestes que tu
faisais pas un chat dans les bras
le cas à ouidah et marque le taper
gentil méchant oui bien à
[Rires]
attends casimir way 30 et nous ni pour
nous là qu'ils sont en train de faire
affirme samir aller alors c est l'autre
et leurs troupes alors ça c'est
l'interprétation de casimir aller à des
concerts
il faut que les deux équipes soient bien
de parts et d'autres
assieds toi hélène voilà comme ça alors
la réponse n'en doute dû commencer à
donner une réponse là je veux dire c'est
durs et mous chloé est tirée du chewing
gum s'étaient tous nous et toi valérie à
portée de vue alors elle s'est fait mal
oh la la c'est ça il a encore un allez
on y va et plus ont un peu comme une
escale est gêné pour faire leur nid mme
thiam retire-t-on
recul un problème parce que du cash des
caches marque à l'autre équipe on l'a
alors là oui mais dans les allées pour
venir occuper tout seul un alors les
deux personnes h au sol toc toc toc toc
toc et voyez encore une fois encore une
fois oui et puis l'autre
bon c'est quoi
non c'est pas ça ici ce sera mieux
mais toi ici du verra mieux divers amis
casimir aulas tient assieds toi voilà
aller comme ça allez tu nous en fait un
autre cas similaire
ouais alors attendons chacun son tour a
donné les devants se marque
il sait pas alors jean david et les
mâles dans ce n'est pas si cher c'est
mais non alors casimir
qu'est-ce que ça casimir vient dans les
rues casimir du transit mais c'était eux
doux doux et et coléreux doux et
coléreux voilà c'est une hormone être
voilés ci citons encore nôtres à l'aller
les noms je me suis aussi casimir allez
allez c'est prier non allez allez les
labels et kazimiya les anneaux casimir
allez bon alors encore un scoop le mois
sauf que moi quelque chose eh bien j'en
vois je sais pas c'était du disparu sans
être aussi à toi tu atteins de nathan
clumeck l'étudiera posé autant contraire
ne faut pas le dire ce qu'il faut pas
lire
bien entendu présent facile à m'estimer
du mime s'illumine dur avoue un excès
alors allez y aurait-il dit pas aux
autres très bien
ben alors les réponses après ça c'était
le premier voyez leur 12e après voilà
c'est ça c'est toi qui m'as venons ces
gens davies qui l'avait dit babeau quel
dommage
il faut nous séparer françois casimir
sont en train de bien s'amuser au revoir